Determine whether the
system has no solutions
or infinite solutions.
So let's think about how
we can go about doing this.
So if at any point we might
not have to solve this entirely
if we somehow get something
that's nonsensical
which will tells us
there's no solutions.
Or we might have to
go further and see
if it's one or
infinite solutions,
although it looks like one
solution isn't an option
here, given how this
question is phrased.
So the way that
you would proceed
to solve three equations
with three unknowns
is you would try to eliminate
variables one by one.
And so first we could try to
eliminate the x variables.
And we could do that,
we can essentially
create two equations
with two unknowns.
The two unknowns
will be y and z.
If we can pair up
these equations
and eliminate x with
each of these pairings.
So for example, we can
pair these first two.
We can pair the last two.
And that's all we would need
to have to eliminate the x's
and still have two equations.
And have all of the information
of these three equations.
But then the third
pairing would be
the first and the
third equation,
But we only have to do
two of these pairings.
Now, just to show you what I
mean by these pairings, what
I want to do is take
these first two.
I'm going to pair this first
pairing right over here,
and I'm going to use them
to eliminate the x terms.
And over here I have
2x, over here I have 8x.
If I could turn this
2x into a negative 8x
I could add both sides of
these equations to each other
and the x terms
would cancel out.
And so the best way to turn
this 2x into a negative 8x
is to multiply this top
equation times negative 4.
When I say multiply, I'm saying
multiply the whole equation,
both sides of it, by negative 4.
So 2x times negative
4 is negative 8x.
Negative 4y times negative 4
is plus 16y, are positive 16y.
z times negative 4 is negative
4z And that's equal to 3 times
negative 4 which is negative 12.
And then I can rewrite this
equation right over here.
It's 8x minus 2y plus
4z is equal to 7.
And now I can add
these both equations.
On the left hand side,
these guys cancel out,
16y minus 2y-- and that
was the whole point
behind multiplying the top
equation by negative 4--
16y minus 2y is 14y.
Negative 4z plus 4z.
These guys actually
cancel out as well.
So actually with
that one pairing,
by multiplying by negative
4 we were actually
able to cancel
out two variables.
So you get 14y is
equal to negative 12
plus 7 is equal to negative 5.
And you can actually
solve for y.
And we don't know if this one
will actually have solutions.
But if we assume it's
going to have a solution,
you could actually solve
for y right over here.
You could divide
both sides by 14.
But let's worry about
that a little bit later.
Let's take the second
pairing right over here.
So once again you have an 8x.
We want to eliminate the x's.
So this one you have an 8x,
here you have a negative 4x.
If you multiply
this times 2, this
is going to become
a negative 8x and it
can cancel with this top one.
So the top equation is 8x
minus 2y plus 4z is equal to 7.
When I say "top equation" I'm
talking about this one right
over here, the top
one in this pairing.
And this bottom
equation, I'm going
to multiply times negative 2.
I'm going to multiply it
times negative 2-- sorry times
positive 2.
I'm going to multiply
it times positive 2.
Negative 4x times
positive 2 is negative 8x.
So I'm going to
multiply it by 2.
So 2 times negative
4x is negative 8x.
2 times y is plus 2y.
2 times negative
2z is negative 4z.
And then 2 times negative
14 is negative 28.
And now we can add
the left hand sides
and add the right hand sides.
These cancel out, those
cancel out, those cancel out.
We actually end up with
nothing on the left hand side.
You get 0 plus 0 plus 0.
And on the right hand side
you get 7 plus negative 28
is negative 21.
Well, this is a
nonsensical answer.
0 can never be equal
to negative 21.
No matter what x,
y, or z you pick,
0 cannot be equal
to negative 21.
And that's because these
second two equations
right over here,
if you view them
as planes in three dimensions,
these right over here
do not intersect.
If you visualize them
in three dimensions,
they're actually
parallel planes.
And since these last two
definitely do not intersect,
we can say that this
system has no solutions.
It doesn't matter if this
first equation intersects
one or both of these.
The fact that these
two don't intersect
tells us that there's no unique
point x, y, z coordinate,
a point in three dimensions that
satisfies all three of them.
Because there's no
unique x, y, z that
can satisfy these two, because
these are parallel planes.
They do not intersect.